[Music]
three
two one
hey guys it's inka welcome back to
another season of trendy versus
traditional where i'll be making trendy
interpretations of your favorite
classics as some of you know last season
i had a lot of different guests to
represent the traditional end but this
season we have a very special guest here
comes the boy
i've been here the entire time thank you
by the way for immortalizing me in the
previous season i didn't die i'm back
and i'm here to cook traditional
versions of your favorite dishes today
we are going to be making
fries
who doesn't love fries i have like a
list of cravings that i always have and
fries is like on top i don't know how
you're gonna make a trendy fry i don't
even know what that means i think what
i'm gonna do is i'm going to put a a
twist on the definition i don't like
when inga throws these like little like
sneaky words around am i at first
thank you very very much happy to be
back let's get to it
hello there sweeties we are going to be
making some traditional fries on my end
of the spectrum here now in my opinion
what makes a good fry is something
that's not too thick not too thin and
has a really good crisp so i'm going to
attempt to tackle that today
let's get into it i am here i have my
potatoes i'm going to be making tornado
fries i think they're still popular
actually right now in south korea i
recently produced a video fries around
the world where you can actually see
what the original one looks like it's
like this massive stick of potato chip
french fry hybrids so it's not going to
look like your regular fry now maybe
this is a topic of debate in terms of
skin on skin off i like it just monotone
fry not a lot of skin happening so first
step is we're going to peel some of
these potatoes here you try and get most
of the skin without taking too much of
the potato meat off is it neat correct
me in the comments if the inside of a
potato is not called the meat first
thing i'm going to do here is actually
just pierce these
little guys
straight through
so now i have little potatoes on sticks
here's a cool hack that i found on the
internet i wanna try and like do a
little spiral down the thing right the
hack is to use a cheese slicer and
actually what's gonna happen is we're
gonna use this to essentially shave it
off just don't shave off your fingers i
did a practice run just now and i almost
did so
here we go wish me luck if you're not
making a mess it's not traditional see
this little sprinkling this is part of
the process and if you don't respect
that click off of this video right now
you know the street food vendors that do
this it looks perfect because they use a
machine i am the machine today and i'm
trying to master this so
i'm really trying here
so let's get started by just
cutting these big boys in half
then let's cut them
into these
kind of nice big
rectangular shapes
what is this shape you know versions of
things that i've done this is definitely
one that's like more focused on
technique i feel like normally we play
around with the flavors or like the
concept of it this one is more like
deceptively simple you know what i'm
saying i'm just here imagining chris
having an easy time just slicing up the
potatoes are you just chilling
not too thick
not too thin if anything it's more
important to just be uniform here's kind
of what we're going for here
look at this here see that traditional
fries here not too thick not too thin we
are preparing them to be
boiled
and with that we have finished
cutting up our little fry babies it's
not perfect but it's a little bit better
hand sliced y'all okay did we not have
budget for the machine
this is not oil this is water since
you're so nice to watch this video i'm
not gonna stand here and make you watch
me boil water okay practice makes
perfect take things slow one slice at a
time
[Music]
a potato that has been hold on away for
it
chris i'm coming for you
now that the water's at a boil we're
going to add
a pinch or two of some salt by the way
the recipe i'm following is a recipe
that will link in the description a
trick with this
is adding a little vinegar to the
boiling water which there's a chemical
reaction that happens that helps the
potato from completely breaking down
like mashed potatoes so we're going to
add about
three
tablespoons
of white vinegar i'm just going to
gently
lower these fries into some water here
i'm going to lower that in
i don't know why i'm using this like i'm
scared of a little hot water i'm not
scared gently gently gently so these
fries are going to go in here for 10
minutes this is where a lot of the
cooking process is going to happen
because the best fries are the crispy
exterior but like the light fluffy
steamy potato interior check back in
soon all right improvement look at this
this is what we're talking about work
hard and you will be rewarded all right
so now that i've kind of mastered it a
little bit i'm gonna make a couple more
i'm pretty confident now we're good to
move on the potatoes have finished
boiling all we have to do is just pull
these fries out they are fork tender i
know they don't look like fries i need
you to relax if you're in the comments
like those don't look like traditional
fries that's making me angry if that's
what's happening now we just need to get
these fries as dry as possible if we're
putting soaking wet steamy fries into an
oil
you're gonna have a bad time next step
is the oil my potato sticks are now off
to the side safe and secure for now i am
going to make the sauce this is going to
be like my secret weapon that hopefully
will push me over the edge but i'm going
to make a honey butter glaze if you will
that i want to like just like paint
across the fries
and then over here i'm also just going
to really quickly whip up the batter
that i'm going to dip the fries in just
to give it that like extra crunch all
right folks these fries are very dry
i'm gonna be honest i didn't expect
everyone to do that um the fries are
panicking a little bit uh the fries are
as
all right so i'm gonna start with the
sauce since that's gonna take a while to
cook down so over here
i'm gonna add some butter honey butter
is a very popular flavor that's paired
with the tornado fries but usually it's
in powder form i should have used honey
butter chips as a coating no
rule number one is we don't want to
overcrowd the oil we need to give
everyone room in the oil to swim around
plus this is only our first fry this is
a two fry fry so i'm going to layer up a
couple of these boys about half the gang
here and we're gonna gently lower into
our hot oil here we go no turning back
first fry into the oil
that's a good noise
let's
turn this down
god damn it
little steamy oil's a little hot i'm
just going to grate some garlic in here
oh that was a nice little plop smells
like garlic bread garlic is in
now i'm going to add in all of this
sugar actually i know it seems like a
lot but it will be good it's gonna be
sweet and salty all right i'm gonna add
some soy sauce as well and it's smelling
really good right now so
i take that as a good sign and also add
a little bit of honey
that's what makes it honey butter well
that did not go quite as expected
traditional fries you need a little
danger element you need to be kept on
your toes we only need these in here for
like 50 seconds less than a minute let's
get them out of there
save the boys onto our paper towel line
sheet oh yeah look at this consistency
already it's looking pretty good but i'm
gonna taste this a little bit oh it's so
sweet okay we're gonna let the oil cool
down just a touch and we're going to
move into our second batch of fries here
second batch of fries going in
fingers crossed this goes a little
smoother easy now you know a lot of
times with like trendier version of
things sometimes like the flavors are
also like more complex you know i think
people really like to really like go out
there and try different seasonings i
hope our judge likes this sweet and
salty like the goal is not to win but
winning is nice you know we've
officially first fried our batch of
fries here next step is letting these
fries cool down we're going to toss them
in the fridge for like 30 minutes before
we go in for our second fry to finish
the job but let's toss these in the
fridge
see you soon
i don't know i blew a kiss let it cook a
little bit here softly simmer and then
on this side i'm just gonna make my
batter really quick
starting with an egg
i'm just breaking that apart first and
then adding in my flour
and
water it's like fries dipped in batter
is that weird is that weird i'm gonna
add a pinch of salt that was more than a
pinch but that's okay and then i'm also
going to add in pepper give me one
second we are going to be
finally moving into our fries that have
cooled down in the fridge after our
initial fry like the first fry we're
going to be working in two batches don't
want to overcrowd the oil i'm not
anticipating quite the uh
volcanic experience that the first fry
was but
you never know ceyla v i don't know if
i'm using that phrase right all right
add some pepper
more pepper
i think that's plenty i just want to
make sure there's no lumps
looking pretty good
batter is done beautiful glaze oh look
at that color you see it it's like a
beautiful caramel
all right so over here
my sauce is still cooking down still
looking a little too liquidy for my
liking so i'm gonna keep reducing this
and then once it's reduced i'm gonna
pour in a bowl and then i think i can
get frying second batch fries going in
here we go gently gently gently
[Music]
i'm keeping a watchful eye on the oil i
would move my mic closer but no one
wants me to see take hot oil to the face
isn't that right everyone here we are i
have my beautiful potato spiral tornado
thingies here batter
glaze over here look at this glaze look
at
oh
secret weapon now i'm going to take one
of these beautiful spirals
oh this beauty is grace and i'm
essentially just going to
spoon the batter over it and make sure
it's all covered like so
there's something about frying anything
but especially french fries i want that
smell all over me i want to smell like
i've been in the oil i want to smell
like i am a french fry i didn't season
this batter too much because i already
have the glaze
drain off the excess let it drip
beautiful okay and now it's going in
here we go
looking very close
oh ah
in the comments ooh ah thank you
let's drop them on to our paper towel
line baking sheet
gently without burning myself
fries are looking good what do the kids
say now
[Music]
already
i will say i'm feeling pretty good so
far the glaze smells incredible that
improvement gave me much confidence so
not to make sure this tastes good
looking at it and
color looks pretty good
oh
it looks pretty good looks pretty good
it smells like a fry i'm gonna let that
cool for a little bit
i'm gonna glaze after i fry all of these
up all right everybody our second batch
of fries are looking golden crispy ingo
watch out these look good
toss them down here let's give a little
off the elbow a little salt bae you know
what i i've earned this
not to be played with
feeling good let's plate i have my
beautiful fries here some look better
than the others i'm going to glaze this
one so i can taste it ready i have my
glaze here just essentially just
painting it on a little bit this sauce
is very flavorful though so i'm like
maybe i shouldn't go too crazy but i
also want to make sure every chip has it
so
i feel like i'm doing an injustice to
traditional fries by like placing them i
feel like anytime you see traditional
fries they're just like slammed into a
bowl and slid across the table and then
just on the side let's keep it classic
keep it simple and it's not open okay
and here it is my friend can i taste it
i'm gonna taste it the beauty of it is
that you don't even have to touch it if
you don't want to so
the flavor is good already most of it i
like to think that that's because it's
really good so i'm gonna glaze the rest
of these
less glaze this time but i'm i'm feeling
pretty good
make sure you get all that audio
everyone i present to you
traditional french fries
three
two one
oh where's your plate i don't halfway
cause it's fair food those look really
good you smell really good i guess we've
arrived at the portion of our show where
we have a judge come in and tell us
which recipe they prefer the trendy or
the traditional a day come on in i read
the surprise
he smelled it yup
chris you're alive
which one should i start with first i
don't know what's happening over here
because the condiment looks serious this
is ketchup okay
let's dig in oh nice that looks nice
sheep thank you very much
that's right
oh
i heard i heard a little crunch this is
something i would compare to like rise
at a diner a diner is traditional so
i'll take that and randy here we go
i don't know how to attack this should i
pull it
oh
hasn't even chowed down on it and i'm
hearing noises
okay
i just got put onto the honey butter
chips
you know the honey this is what it
tastes like a day we need an answer we
need a verdict which fry do you prefer
so when you think about how can you
improve upon the fries that we're all
used to inka just figured it out and i
think this is my winner of trinity
versus traditional flag
get out of here
cheers
home style fries deserved let us know
what you want to see next we're going to
be making more trendy versus traditional
put it in the comments tell us what to
do
until next time
bye
you